giuseppe pontiggia ha scritto un
bellissimo libro che ho preso in mano
per pensare a questa storia
questo libro si chiama nati due volte e
dedicato ai bambini che nascono due
volte che devono imparare a muoversi in
un mondo che la prima nascita reso più
difficile e dove la seconda nascita
dipende dalle persone
similmente la bellezza nasce due volte
ed è la seconda volta un sole giaguaro
che si nasconde negli occhi la prima
volta nella realtà poi entra dentro di
noi e siamo noi a farla crescere e negli
occhi risiede come le essenziale ma come
facciamo a renderla persistente farla
crescere rende la vera farla diventare
solida come la prima parte della
bellezza che nasce la prima volta sola
allora ho pensato a questo paesaggio che
ho fotografato
era il 18 agosto 2015 e ora vorrei
presentarvi quello che la stava
guardando nel momento in cui io facevo
la foto
lui sì si chiamava nichi era il nostro
cane ci aveva adottato nel 2010 scavando
in mezzo alla sabbia sotto il nostro
ombrellone nichi non era bello non era
di razza però abbiamo instaurato con lui
un rapporto fondato sugli occhi è già
cucito addosso il senso della meraviglia
e quel giorno lui guardava questa questa
strana bellezza del sole d'occhio e in
mezzo fra lui e noi fra il sole doppio e
noi lo guardavamo c'era un aquilone e
lui ci ha insegnato un po a a vivere con
questo muso grosso sbalorditi dal senso
della bellezza poi
e successo proprio un anno dopo dopo
quel 18 agosto
lui è andato via queste cose sono strane
perché il 18 agosto è il giorno in cui
sono nati i nostri due figli
abbiamo pensato di rivedere un po le
foto e ci siamo ritrovati negli occhi di
nicky perché se vi avvicinate piano
piano in questa foto ci trovate a me la
mia moglie federica negli occhi lo
guardiamo divertito in questo gioco di
specchi
poi comincia a capire che certe volte la
morte in qualche modo ti aumenta la
capacità della vita allora quella sera
del 18 di quest'anno
io mi sono seduto davanti al tramonto e
ho pensato
ovviamente pensavo a lui ma ho pensato a
una poesia di silvano agosti
straordinaria che apre il lettere dalla
chiesa di questo mondo lontano
immaginario e lì c'è un poeta che il
viso che scrive attraverso silvano e
scrive con noi o senza di noi
verrà il tramonto e sarà bellissimo c'è
un noi più grande di noi che ci
comprende che ci rende più solidi che ci
rende presenti anche dopo quando noi
siamo partiti da qualche parte perché la
bellezza nasce due volte e le persone
sono quelle a compiere la bellezza
qui stiamo a matera questi sono i denti
amici straordinari ho conosciuto da poco
siamo impegnati in questi giorni dal
primo settembre
nell'open design school di matera non
sappiamo ancora cosa sia l'open design
lo stiamo inventando e stavamo
camminando ai margini del del vuoto
della bis stavamo guardando matera la
stavamo aspettando mentre si spegneva la
luce del sole mentre stava per diventare
quello che un artigiano straordinario ci
ha raccontato che un tempo accadeva
quando si accendono le luci di matera
quando si accendevano molti secoli fa
c'erano i guardiani
della della città delle persone e
osservavano tutte le luci che si
accendevano da ogni casa di materia che
c'era legge e si dovevano avere accese
per avere il controllo delle persone
quando qualche luce mancava quei
guardiani andavano a cercare le persone
in questo cielo ribaltato
ovviamente abbiamo pensato quello che è
che non esiste bellezza senza le persone
che ci camminano dentro perché loro sono
il senso e la nostra storia
e proprio per questo io ho cambiato da
un po di tempo la direzione abbiamo dato
rispetto alla direzione di un architetto
normalmente quello che fa costruisce ma
io mi occupo da un po di tempo appunto
di costruzioni processi di
partecipazione per questo esistono tanti
strumenti che si combinano perché ogni
processo che coinvolge una presa delle
decisioni più complessa con i cittadini
è un argomento che è un'opera da sarto
molto semplice molto artigianale ed è
una storia intensa e ci sono due cose
che in queste storie intense sono
fondamentali la prima è raccontarle
queste storie queste avventure di sarti
e di persone la seconda è spiegare i
metodi trasferirli portarli altrove
perché noi non siamo depositari di una
conoscenza esclusiva
siamo semplicemente operatori di voli
possibili e quindi nella sostanza e il
ruolo è quello di proteggere le visioni
protegge della bellezza perché i
contenuti delle comunità risuonano
questo 9 space technology ma la cosa
straordinaria è che le persone qui si
accendono e si accendono perché ognuno
di loro
in ogni caso di una comunità risuona con
le altre e risuona costruendo il senso
della bellezza e in qualche modo una
condizione che paragona la bellezza alla
partecipazione
entrambe sono politiche generative
in queste storie di processi partecipati
non ha importanza anche fila stai
se sei davanti se sei di dietro se sei
un amministratore o una persona
qualsiasi
dentro una scuola perché ciò che è
veramente importante sono le idee e la
loro capacità di propagarsi verso il
mondo e questa programmazione è il senso
questa accensione del senso è quello che
poi può rimanere in una comunità e
risvegliare processi più deboli e
portarli altrove falli migrare e sulla
migrazione io ho costruito un po un
metodo molto sartoriale di lavoro perché
la bellezza è una foresta imperfetta di
persone la partecipazione a storie anche
a ride ma astori anche di foreste
pluviali che si spostano e quindi quello
che vedete in alto è un muro nomade un
cielo quello che sta in basso e un
tavolo nomade è una scrittura istantanea
dei discorsi che pratico da un po di
tempo io ascolto e scrivo le persone
genero nuvole di pensieri non c'è mai il
nome delle persone che parlano ma sono
in qualche modo destini incrociati
foreste di senso che restano in un luogo
migrano questa è la fondazione di un
dell'hub di bari ma è un luogo dove in
qualche modo le persone hanno lasciato
traccia per andare altrove e in qualche
costruzione del senso le persone si
ritrovano per spostarsi e per darci
anche nuove forme di pensiero di queste
alleanze per costruire il senso della
partecipazione ce n'è una che vi voglio
raccontare quella che è venuta qui a
terlizzi qualche anno fa c'era una
rigenerazione urbana è abbastanza
importante un un intervento
significativo che prendevo un pezzo
della città nel cuore di questo pezzo
c'era una scuola una scuola elementare
e allora la scuola è stato un fulcro
generativo la scommessa è stata
collegare
la pubblica amministrazione alla scuola
e poi a tutto il mondo che stava intorno
sono stati 40 giorni più di 50
laboratori e loro parlano lo stesso
linguaggio
la pubblica amministrazione organizza il
pensiero analizza le forze le debolezze
usa i fogli colorati e questi fogli
atterrano dentro il mondo dei bambini
inutile dirvi che il mondo i bambini
sono rivoluzionari usano gli strumenti
che sono stati inventati per percorsi
strategici
molto meglio degli adulti e poi c'è la
preside poi qui c'è graziana che
un'amica molto brava una sociologa che
spesso accompagna i percorsi che faccio
e hanno insomma inventato un'azione in
cui una palestra era una degli spazi
immaginati un campo da gioco
straordinario di fantasia di bellezza di
senso e hanno inventato loro il
sottotitolo del laboratorio hanno detto
che i bambini sono fiori selvatici ed
effettivamente non costituiscono lungo
di questa foresta pluviale della
partecipazione ma sono il senso migrante
di fiori estremamente resistenti che ci
danno la possibilità di capire che i
processi di partecipazione possono
generare bellezze diverse e sempre
imprevedibili
e poi questo processo è finito hanno
fatto la trasformazione il progetto è
cambiato è stato adattato con l'infanzia
hanno trovato delle soluzioni comportato
gli interessi diversi e poi uno va via
va in altri luoghi fa altri progetti e
torna dopo qualche anno sono tornato
questa quest'inverno per altri lavori e
il dirigente che ha detto ma ti porto a
vedere il luogo ero curioso per capire
ma che cosa sarà successo
cosa hanno costruito e io sono andato ho
trovato questa cosa questo un pezzo
della palestra e lì è atterrato millo
milo è uno straordinario brighter che
sta trasformando pezzi di città in tutto
il mondo e un pugliese e di mesagne è
arrivato lì lancio del dirigente che sta
lì
entra di lato insomma è abbastanza
contento anche perché il comune ha speso
molto meno di quanto potesse immaginare
ma il discorso fondamentale di chi è chi
è stato il responsabile della bellezza e
dirigente i fiori selvatici bambini non
ha importanza quello che si è creato in
questo luogo è una condizione favorevole
dello spirito
i bambini fiori selvatici sono atterrati
probabilmente una condizione casuale
però io non credo che sia così per in
fondo veramente in qualche modo la la
realtà si è trasformata dando alla
fantasia
una speranza di abitare il senso futuro
della bellezza che ora è senso presente
anche qui c'è la scuola
e qui c'è un'immagine che mi viene in
dono da una persona speciale che è
quello del signore lì che sta in alto a
sinistra
lui si chiama piero paolicelli e del mio
gemello diverso mi ero portato questa
immagine dentro il ted per matera poche
settimane fa gli ho telefonato l'altro
giorno ho detto mi presti la tua
immagine così ne parlò anche una
staffetta è ovviamente l'abbiamo fatto e
un hacker civico si occupa di digitale
di di innovazione delle comunità e qui
sono tutti i docenti questi docenti
polaris imberti mim aprile
pina suriano hanno stabilito una rete
insieme abbiamo costruito una piccola
avventura nella scuola fondata su un un
automa che ha inventato fiero di cui ora
vi parlo voi conoscete telegram
telegramma è un'applicazione molto
semplice come whatsapp bene piero è un
grandissimo produttore di bot che sono
degli automi che funzionano su domanda
in sostanza voi trovate su whatsapp una
sede su telegramma una serie di
applicazioni gratuite come queste
lui si inventa divina commedia bot che
cos'è la divina commedia di dante nel
cellulare poi inserito un funzione
gativo mettete una parola dante risponde
e vi individua il punto della linea
commedia che a quella parola
e allora abbiamo pensato ma che facciamo
di questa cosa portiamo là nella scuola
abbiamo fatto qualche sperimentazione
questa è una delle più intense che
abbiamo fatto abbiamo capito ma lo
sapevamo già che la scuola e il posto
delle rivoluzioni ed è andato accendi
dante che questo format che ora
porteremo un po per l'italia è che cosa
accade qual è lo scopo
i ragazzi sono persone e sono le persone
che accendono dante come fanno un
professore della classe due professori
di due classi si uniscono insieme fanno
un gruppo un gruppo su telegram nel
gruppo metti il divina commedia bot
dante è stato il gruppo comincia una
sfida classe capovolta per dieci giorni
non esiste orario scolastico di giorno
di notte noi siamo nascosti nel gruppo
non facciamo niente li osserviamo questi
cominciano interagire qual è lo scopo
devono trovare link pertinenti quindi
scelgono un canto interrogano dante ma
cercano collegamenti pertinenti che
possano essere un aumento della divina
commedia perché fra qualche giorno loro
devono andare in classe tutti insieme e
devono inserire questi collegamenti nel
bot
attraverso la collaborazione di piero
che è persona splendida che sa fare
questo in tempo reale
questo aumento di senso come lo viviamo
io mi porto un foglio molto grande e lo
vedete gli in fondo lo stand diamo tutto
mettiamo il canto questo il canto iii
del paradiso lo inseriamo sul margine
superiore e cerchiamo ovviamente di fare
un confronto in brain storming in
tempesta con i ragazzi loro hanno già
raccolto un bel bacino di
i collegamenti ma quali sono utili che
cos'è la pertinenza stiamo lavorando su
la più grande opera della storia
dell'uomo su questo hanno lavorato
critici di tutto il mondo cosa possono
fare dei ragazzi ei ragazzi possono
accendere dante e allora quando
discutiamo sui link loro ci devono dire
che cosa sono questi collegamenti sono
collegamenti italia riguardano cioè il
mondo laterale visionario sono
collegamenti di terra aderiscono al
testo sono collegamenti di fuoco sono
evocazioni fulminanti o di arco di
testimonianze racconti attorno al testo
e così nasce un gioco di posizionamento
perché quel foglio ii diventa
l'orizzonte quindi io scrivo in tempo
reale questi collegamenti e attorno
quella tempesta che si crea è così piano
piano questo muro comincia a crescere
il professore alla pari lavorare insieme
non c'è chi è in prima fila e che in
seconda e comincia una tempesta e
aumenta e aumenta entrano nella divina
commedia queste parole operatrici di
volo di dante che agiscono insieme a
molte altre di molti altri tempi di
molte altre storie e il muro cresce e
cresce attraverso singolari forme dello
spirito del corpo della letteratura del
cinema della pittura e alla fine vedete
che si è composto una cosa assolutamente
strano un arcobaleno un arcobaleno che
poi alla fine diventa un aquilone alla
fine ce ne andiamo
i ragazzi il giorno dopo mi mandano una
foto l'avevano tolto staccato quel muro
che era nomade dalla parte più bassa
della dell'aula in cui eravamo molto
grande e l'hanno portato nella loro aula
l'hanno messo in alto vicino alla
finestra proprio prossima al cielo e
quando ho ricevuto il giorno dopo da uno
li oro quella foto ho visto che quella
lì non era taranto soltanto era kabul e
forse quei ragazzi erano diventati
calciatori aquiloni e che quello era un
aquilone
che stava volando nel cielo non ha
importanza se imperfetto perché quella
cosa imperfetta e rimane sarà il canto
del paradiso
e così anche nicky che non c'è più
può continuare a vederlo volare